Let's take some time to look at
a blogging app we've designed,
as well as some feedback on it.
In order to look at which
bits of feedback are useful.
So, here is the app.
What we're trying to figure out is
whether this app design works as
a blogging platform.
Can users easily find blogs they want,
and post their content easily?
When we asked users to
find a particular blog, or
to post their own content,
they were generally confused.
Users had a lot of things
to say about this design.
I find this really overwhelming,
and I'm not sure where to go.
I really like the title.
You should use Comic Sans for the font.
I can't find a way to post here.
Which icon is the blog I need?
Remember, valuable feedback is
any feedback that ties a feeling
from the user to a specific
part of the app.
Now, which of these bits of
feedback are useful for us?